-Tracy and I have
a lot of history together.
Most people think that we me
on "Saturday Night Live,"
but we go back
further than that.
Tracy and I
actually were together
at the same cooking networ
back in the early '90s.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Yeah, it was called EatsTV.
-What were we doing?
-I know, man.
Between shows,
we would do these segments
where we gave the audience
cooking tips,
but to keep
our line readings fresh,
our director
wouldn't let us see the line
until while we were shooting
So, we were reading them for the
first time right there on set.
Well, I found
some of our old footage.
-What?
-I swear.
So, for the first time
in decades,
here is Tracy and I on EatsTV.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're watching EatsTV,
your home for recipes,
restaurants,
and really good food.
Stay tuned for tips
from the EatsTV kitchen.
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome to EatsTV.
[ Laughter ]
Coming up, I'll teach you ho
to make homemade Panda Express
Step one, break into a zoo
Step two, steal a panda.
Step three, realize you're
in way over your head
and just order Panda Express
Bon app--
Bon pandatite.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I've got a great recipe
for stumpkin pie.
First, you got to find
fresh stumpkin.
But don't get one with a face.
Those stumpkins are scary.
[ Laughter ]
I hate scary stumpkins.
They's got skeleton teeth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-My favorite foods
in this order are
cheese, chickpeas,
peas, chicks, chick cheese
Did I say peas already?
Quiches, peaches,
cheesy Reese's,
beets, beefs --
heck, all the meats --
fries and pies,
and wings and thighs
and telling lies.
[ Laughter ]
Noodles, strudels,
Fruit Loop kugels.
Yodels...
♪♪ Yodel-ay-hee-hoo ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Oh, so hoarse.
My favorite food is horse.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-On Thanksgiving,
chew like Chewbacca.
Chewbacca used to my favorit
"Star Wars" character,
but then he got behind
on his child support payments.
[ Laughter ]
-Tracy, here.
-Huh?
-Oh.
We really did this.
-No, here. No, here.
[ Laughter ]
Eggs -- Eggs, flour,
water, and milk.
-That's what I used to use
for birth control.
It doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
I got eight kids off the books
-The best cooking advice
I can give you
is to always use
fresh ingredient,
like this lemon that was jus
picked this morning.
[ Laughter ]
Yummy.
I'm glad I'm doing this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I call Tony the Tiger
Anthony because of the respect
of what he does for breakfast.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How come the cat food
is called Fancy Feast?
Do cats think
they're better than me?
Well, guess what, cat,
I can eat cat food, too.
I want chicken.
I want liver.
I want to sleep in a littl
basket on top of the heate
and clean myself with my tongue.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's not delivery,
and it's not DiGiorno.
It's Britney, bitch!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Don't waste your money
on expensive takeout
when you can make a deliciou
meal right at home.
-I like waffles.
That's why I turned my house
into a waffle house.
I sleep on the grille.
It burns my buns.
[ Laughter ]
Waffle House burns my buns
-EatsTV.
Who wants seconds?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. My thanks to Tracy Morgan
right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]